I'm like to welcome Mariana thank you
good morning everyone Thank You Nadine
for presenting me my name is Mariana let
me just so today I'm going to talk a lot
of a little bit about my thoughts around
culture so the first image I put up
there I put it there because I want to
show the boxes the boxes where we put it
people in every day a social worker and
we see this boxes and the work we do all
the time so when someone's sitting in
front of us we sometimes put them in the
agent box does that mean we know who's
sitting in front of us we put them in
the Hispanic box does that mean we not
now know the background of this person
well the reality is that the agent
person could come from Thailand China
Japan the spanning person could come
from Costa Rica Mexico Ecuador these are
all different countries they're all
different cultures so a social workers
we will be serving immigrants from all
over the world especially in New York
City dirt and even in this building we
interact with people from different
countries and with different cultural
backgrounds everyday we we need to be
aware of that the truth is that is it is
many times easier to put someone in a
box than to explore who they are what
their cultural background is you want to
be able to define count describes its
systematized however there are things we
just need to explore especially if want
to meet people where they are throughout
this for years living in this country I
have I have been faced being inserted in
a box many times when I am asked where
you're from and I say from Mexico
certain assumptions start to happen
people think I like salsa de salsa music
I know how to dance I love tacos some of
the things may be true some may not be
but this is what it automatically is
thought about Mexican culture but there
is so much more to culture and culture
affects our day-to-day life and the way
we view the world growing up in a
different culture than the one I live in
now makes culture so much more evident I
remember my first when I moved to the
states and I started working I'm going
to to work the first month one of my
co-workers was sick and I asked her oh
you you look like you're not feeling
well you look kind of sick and she took
this a little bit like as an offense and
when I had said this in Spanish in
Mexico this was a way to show empathy so
even though we were speaking the same
language what i was saying meant very
different different things it meant
something to her and something totally
different to me there are so many
components to culture and language is
one of them we can understand culture
through language for example in the
upper ravick in arabic there is no word
for a secular so what does that mean for
their culture does that mean that the
existence of God is not question these
are questions we can ask ourselves and
in Kenya people say I'm sorry when
something happens to another person for
example working with the social workers
there every time a girl fell or came to
the office and was sick they would say
I'm sorry when I dropped my papers on
the floor they would say I'm sorry what
does that mean what does this mean for
them the more I learn about culture the
more I have been able to observe how
much it impacts people's lives culture
is very complex it is for foreign by
socioeconomic status race customs for
all those things there and many more so
at school and the school we talk a lot
about cultural competency but what does
that really mean how do we become
culturally competent well I think that
being
more aware of how our own culture
impacts us in our day-to-day lives we
become more open to understanding other
people's cultures without judgment
without assumptions and accepting
differences it's a way to start there's
no there's no book or manual that's
going to explain the sudden you're going
to read and you're going to be
culturally competent it's not like go
right and then you're culturally
competent so what I just to end I would
say let's not put people in a box